hello everyone the great thing about
being alive in the age of Internet well
the age of fast internet is being able
to watch the world champion play chess
online this game here it was suggested
to me by a subscriber Paul betting I was
suggested to me yesterday and that this
game was played yesterday in the pro
chesley Magnus Carlsen is playing
against the vibe of story an Indian
Grandmaster who became a grandmaster at
the age of 15 years and two months and
at the time he became a Grandmaster he
was India's 27th Grandmaster and the
27th youngest ever in the world and
while you'll remember that Bobby Fischer
when he got his Grandmaster title at the
age of 15 that was pretty unthinkable
you know becoming a grandmaster at such
a young age but the bar you know
increased a lot over the years and today
Bobby Fischer wouldn't even wouldn't
even fit the top thirty youngest
grandmasters in the world so let's see
this game and for those of you who are
maybe you know bored by defending
against Eve or maybe Carson's idea here
I will give you just the incentive you
need to start you know really crushing
your opponents as this game really has
everything you know when a world
champion starts his game off by
sacrificing a couple of bones and then
start sacrificing pieces it really
doesn't get any better than this so
let's see this game story goes for e4
and we have d5 crossing goes for the
Scandinavian defense he captures on d5
and on Knight to f6 the modern variation
d5 and we have Bishop to g4
now f3 we have Bishop back to f5 and c4
e6 D captures on e6 and now Knight to c6
and here you can see that the black
already and white already grabbed two
pawns he can always go he captures on f7
but he captures on f7 isn't the best
idea here as black King will be pretty
safe on f7 he can always artificially
castle later he can simply go before
check bring the rook into the game and
white should definitely play something
like Bishop to e3 but still blacks black
is gonna ignore this e 6 pawn he's just
gonna go tonight before threatening
Knight c2 and continue his attack but
this knight to c6 move sorry decided to
play ECAD force on f7 would check
Carlsen played King captures and now
comes Bishop to e3
and here comes Bishop to g5 to b4 check
and now what do you do here well you you
could try a lot of things you could try
for example Bishop to d2 but Bishop to
d2 then you get Knight capture son
before the knight is again threatening
to jump to c2 which check rock is coming
3/8 so white white doesn't really gain
anything from this after Bishop to b4
check white could also try Knight to c3
but then comes rook e8 attacking the
bishop on e3 and after the Queen defense
now comes Queen captures on d4 and after
Queen characters Knight captures again
the knight is threatening to jump to the
sea to the bishop is still hanging and
prevent both threats white would have to
go for a queenside castle here but then
rook captures rook captures and after
Bishop captures pawn captures and rook
captures would check King d1 and c5 you
can see that black equalized in material
and his position is much better his
pieces are much more reactive this rock
is coming to be 8 the pawn structure is
better White's pawn structure is pretty
terrible and all of whites pieces are
undeveloped so after this Bishop to b4
move we have king to f2 but King to have
2 is an option but again there weren't
really any good moves here and it's
interesting that as of as of this moment
for example from this game alone you
could maybe do like 20 chess puzzles and
they would all be interesting here costs
and goes for rook to e8 we have 90 to c3
and now comes the only move that gives
custom the advantage and that is rook
captures on e3 would with a very
interesting idea
King captures on e3 if you don't capture
the rook you're just you know you're
just losing so King chapters on e3 and
now comes Knight captures and before
cousin offers a second piece after the
rook so what do you do here can this
night be captured well if you play Queen
captures on before you get Queen to e7
and now that the queen is on e7 I notice
how the Queen is eyeing the c5 square
therefore Bishop to c5 is a pretty
terrible threat so now you don't really
have a lot of options here if you decide
to play something like King to have to
of course Bishop to c5 wins the Queen
immediately if you play something like
King to d2 then sorry then you get a
rope to d8 again losing the Queen and
lastly if you go King to f4 then then
you have a king on f4 that's pretty
terrible in itself but not only that
it's actually a force to checkmate in
five with nice to h5 checked the king
has nowhere to go only available option
is to capture the Bishop on f5 and after
we play this Queen three six check King
moves and now Bishop to e7 forcing the
King to capture even the knight or you
can prolong checkmate for one more move
with Queen to f6 but simply King
characters and now Queen to g6 this is
checkmate the bishop is guarding the h4
square so after this Knight captures on
d4 we have King back to F 2 so the
knight can't be captured and here Bishop
back to c5 now preparing all sorts of
discoveries and again you have to figure
out what to do here you could try
something like before to deflect the
Bishop from c5 and then give up the
night and see treated to gain at least
some counter play but for example
running away with King to g3 simply not
allowing any any any discoveries I would
actually result in a quick checkmate so
like I said there are so many puzzles to
be created from this game here you're
welcome to find the a checkmate in three
as it's quite interesting so a couple of
seconds for you to pause the video so
for those of you who found it
congratulations it's quite an
interesting checkmate
the idea is Knight to e2 check as you
can see the bishop is now covering the
f2 square the king can go back if you
capture it then Knight to h5 this is
checkmate
as again this is covered by the Bishop
h4 is covered by the Queen f4 is covered
by the night the king has nowhere to go
and if you don't capture the night if
you play something like let's say King
to h4
then doesn't really matter nice to d7 I
discovered check from the queen king
and now Knight to f4 is checkmate so a
lot of very interesting moves here so
after Bishop to c5 sir II tried Knight
to a4 going for the bishop this way but
now simply Bishop the c2 and there is no
way to save the Queen if you try and
save the Queen you're either going to
lose it anyway or again you're getting
checkmated so if you play something like
queen c1 Queen d2 doesn't really matter
Knight to b3 trick opens up a discovered
check to the King and attacks the Queen
so after Knight captures simply capture
this is what check you block and the
Knight captures on a1 completely winning
for black and on the other hand after
this Bishop to C 2 if you try to save
the Queen by playing something like
Queen to e1 now there are no discovered
checks that actually win the Queen but
you have something better Knight to f5
check so what do you do here if you
capture the bishop Knight captures to
remove checkmate you get Queen to d4
check King e2 and now Queen to e3
checkmate and after this Knight to f5
check if you play King to e2 immediately
then you get Queen to d3 again this is
checkmate
so after this is Bishop to c2 attacking
the Queen Sri decided to capture the
knight the bishop and c5 Knight captures
on c5 we have special characters on d1
rook captures
now pinning the knight on d4 but now
Queen to e7 if rook captures and before
then Queen captures on c5 so before
protecting the night and now rook to e8
again you can't capture the knight on d4
if you capture it then you get to Queen
to e1 and this will be checkmate so here
sorry tried Bishop to d3 but now comes
Queen to e3 check King F 1 now be 693
for Knight captures Bishop captures and
c5 now B captors on c5 and now comes
rock captures on e4 pawn captures and
now Queen to f4 check first King you
want now Queen captures on e4 check King
f2 and now Queen to c2 check the King
has to come back to protect the rook and
e1
King to e1 and now simply be captures on
c5 and
was in this position that vibe of sorry
resigned the game as a white really
doesn't have any moves to play you can't
really you can there's no way for you to
develop the rook on h1 the knight can
never move as you have to keep an eye on
D 2 square because of Quinta e to
checkmate and even even if you try
something like rook to d2 then a couple
of maneuvering moves will again leave
white without a move so again there's no
way for you to develop if you try
something like 92 black and simply
capture it now you can't capture the
night because of Queen to be one check
picking up the rook on h1 and even if
you try rook to f1 check first followed
by King g6 again you can't capture it
because going to be one will again be
picking up the rook on f1 so yeah after
this B captures on c5 sorry resigned the
game and a brilliant victory for world
champion max Magnus Carlsen it's really
you know really in this style of old
masters that's why I used the title
cousin summons his inner Murphy I didn't
really think of a better one but I think
it's pretty fitting so that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I will put a link
in the description below where you can
check out some of crossings other games
from the protest League where he streams
them online himself
it's he was a guest on your mood with
cameras channel so it's pretty
interesting to check it out if you enjoy
his games Thank You Sean Wilcox and for
sending me that video and I would like
to thank if tuffly if the levee for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
think all for watching and I will see
you soon and yeah one more thing I did
say I will start covering the towel
versus Botvinnik 1960 World Championship
match but still preparing it I'm reading
up on Todd's own book under 1960 World
Championship match as there are a lot of
very interesting comments by tal himself
there so I really want to prepare for
this series so thank you all and I will
see you soon